hi I'm Matt Welch with nick gillespie we
are co-authors of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America which
is newly out in paper book new forward
or after one of those words go out in
your local bookstore and find it we're
on ask a libertarian day the next
question comes from the wonderfully
named Todd Welch by email I am a
libertarian-leaning Republican I have
two sons that are developmentally
disabled both either have attendant or
do attend public school special
education how would school choice work
with special needs kids Nick yeah I
think it's a good question I have two
children also in public schools
basically if you turn all public
education and we go through this in the
book we have a lengthy chapter on fixing
our policy suggestions to fix K through
12 education but if you voucherize
public school education you will allow
and you turn all public schools K
through 12 into schools of choice you're
going to get better service at lower
costs and more effective means of
communicating with people including
special needs kids I think what you'll
see is the ability of schools to tailor
themselves more successfully to
particular populations of students with
particular needs yo los SE philanthropic
organizations ready to step up and help
to top off things for people who can't
afford you know that what their children
need in terms of education that's one
way of looking at it and that's just
within the narrow confines of voucher
izing the existing system and I think
what we talk a lot about backpack
funding in our book just basically
putting the amount of money that we
spend on kid per average in the backpack
and let their parents choose a school
within that part of the way the backpack
funding is being rolled out in the few
places where it's being tried like a new
orleans louisiana it special needs kids
get more money in their backpack because
they require more money to be spent out
there i think that's how the future will
look like and instead of people being
sentenced to their local school or the
closest school that has a special ed
program you will see an actual flowering
of choice of people who are specializing
this and believe in that
of Education strongly we will be back in
just a few minutes with the next
installment of ask a libertarian 2012
celebrating the paperback edition of the
declaration of independence in bookstore
soon please pre-order now thanks